who father Donlan no it's John okay here
we go just watching a game there the
tournament just started the timer is
going crazy it's a 30 minute tournament
there we go okay double those points
it's making a move they're just watching
a game and this tournament started
slightly earlier they should give me
points they should double the points and
I should get the W key mistakes have
been doubled - whoa finally up there
that last tournament was not the case
though no it wasn't okay D for D for I
don't think I've played this guy before
no I didn't okay I want to get this get
this Center
Oh Knight here we're gonna take that oh
okay you could do that some trades and
now I want to get here pinpoint that
pawn Knight their queen there let's
watch over for tricky stuff on c3 it's a
weak point right here
not gonna take so quickly Queen here
might be good though yeah
he's just way too tricky I want to get
rid of him and I'm gonna continue with
this although I'm dropping this pawn
although I could take and I'm on this
pawn bishop back that's a good move
let's defend here and I want to get
right behind that I can't move my knight
yeah it's gonna beat oh I didn't want to
do that all my knight is safe oh this is
not good this is not good oh my goodness
is this not good 29 seconds actually I
have a lead with the time I'm on the
rook they're gonna give a check where is
the tricky night when you need him
somebody tell me I didn't want to play
g3 by the bishop I'm on the bishop
where's the mate
I got a mate just take him my knight is
tricky he is a tricky tricky guy
that night oh that's an interesting
sacrifice
that's an interesting sacrifice my king
is gonna come back okay now I could get
that pond but their ponds are very fast
King position King position I got the
bishop that's exactly what I needed
okay now I could get these pawns at
least ok now I'll come around here I
need time burners
I'm gonna be cut off oh man I was
holding my breath there six six six and
a bunch of trees or are there a bunch of
trees we're gonna see whoa was I trying
to do there okay throw this H pond down
he is a giant thorn so the plan here is
to trade LightScribe bishops and look
for made on G to hit the Queen Queen
here now that would've been good my
night back to doing something
okay trade darks for bishops I guess I
guess do I have any dark square control
we're gonna see about that I want to get
there dark square Bishop on push I want
to open up the see file that's where
their king is anything better open that
up undermined this pond undermined this
pond open files towards their king
that's the plan Oh mate threat night
here's main that's me she is a minimal
amount of material a night in pond
controlling just enough squares course
the king only had one square to go to
okay let's stay would stay ahead of the
game here get a battery along this
diagonal eliminate there dark square
Bishop and then look for me this wasn't
good now the night is developing with
temp I should have played Knight d2
let's trade maybe as soon as this night
was I could exchange him off now he's
weak there's enough support for this
advance there isn't I haven't there
wasn't enough support so now I could
kick my opponent around open up the H
file it's opened up I get rid of their
dark square Bishop and look for made on
h8 it's happening very soon actually
pawn push I think I could still take
pawn takes Knight Queen h6
still in the rook and I still have h8
available they resigned back to
tournament 20 2012 six okay
double the points we're gonna have the
caro-kann again the caro-kann again is a
favorite oh they were in pre-move mode
their take here take this night and I'm
gonna hang on to this pun I wanna hang
on to him I want to do this
and I'm gonna hang on to that too
although this is this isn't so great
let's pin the night fortunately that
move was their own take him out I want
to make sure I keep this pond under
control still have enough support for it
but it's an annoying pin a very very
annoying pin okay now I don't have to
worry about that so much I want to
connect my nights and then sack here or
something let me just do this - sure up
everything my queen wants to probably
sneak around where my knight has a ton
of pressure 27 seconds not a lot of time
pawn push next let's just open stuff up
Knight takes this this pawn is pinned
his pod could be captured actually I
want to sacrifice on this square
hopefully this works
whoa I wasn't expecting that I'm down
material King up I need um sneaky checks
or something oh I can't do that
11 seconds I have a lot of time cool
trade probably gonna have that I'm gonna
push my push my pawn to Victory Lane can
he be stopped seven seconds or the
checks
can I go fast please just some checks
tricky night checks another check I'm
moving so fast more checks
Oh down on time I had a fight back in
that one whoa oh okay that got too crazy
that got way too crazy I got out of
control I don't like those positions
really get out of control okay
be six that bishops gonna come back and
okay so much for that so much for that
maybe they take that okay I want to keep
this closed dark square control I could
get on e5 this is a good post for my
queen I can't move my knight just yet f7
would kill me han push I want my knight
there my knight there would be very good
okay he's there in time I'm hitting the
bishop and I'm defending f7 let's see
here my knight position I want to get
rid of their knight activate activate
that rook if Bishop here I take how I
don't want to drop that pawn it's a pawn
push here oh I didn't even check to see
if the bishop moves if I'm going to run
into any trouble oh I have an idea I
think okay let's take him out first and
now I do this secure my knight position
the rook is close to trapped 28 seconds
each the rook is active but my knight is
dominant oh I thought I could take the
bishop not the case though I'm looking
to get some pigs okay this is brutal now
or is it no it's not the bishop could
back up let's throw some checks in and
now a tricky for can I get one Brook and
then another after they take mine if
they take mine if they even take mine
let's run away let's run away let's give
a check here and then let's just do this
I could take but I get a bunch of
material a bunch of material take what
to check
get this guy advancing time issue
they're down on time
now stalemates keep rolling there down
on time back determine 4231 2020 who
known a fries okay
21 minutes remain a lot of time Nonna
fries always gives me difficult time
pon takes no let's not go with that
thing come I always played this setup
this sort of stone wall said upon takes
is probably available right here I could
take pressure on this diagonal there
might be some pond push a timely let's
top B 4 B 4 would resolve this tension I
want to keep this tension if I recapture
I'm on this point let me think I'm safe
to Castle or our a my let's do this if I
castled I think Bishop takes in the
Knight to d7 was available so where does
my knight belong now these squares are
the ones that I want to observe I want
to watch out for that build might build
my center sneak my knight in kick this
night out with f6 okay they're gonna
challenge my knight because they
recognize that it's a strong piece they
still can't advance here because the
pressure that I maintain on the square
let's keep this lock down and I think I
want to play f5 close up this Center not
so fast actually the Knights gonna come
back I'm gonna do this no they're doing
a fork here 22 seconds I got to go
quicker I'm on the knight twice take
this pawn and then do what okay now I'm
gonna take let's open this up I think
it's helpful now to open it up and now
they could have taken there with the
rook 16 seconds okay we're gonna have
mass exchanges here I'm pretty sure mass
exchanges
and it's endgame I'm up upon and I want
to centralize my king I have majority
where I have a majority and I got to be
careful there's gonna be a pawn push
here oh I should just take in that poem
why did I do that
oh no no six seconds they took they got
that pun
I gotta go fast I could take that I have
to watch out for they're sneaky pawn
moves oh why am i moving my King just
move this pawn he's past three seconds
it's not easy to pre move not there
where the pre moves they're down on time
wow these are ugly games can I get a
clean win
are there any clean wins out there okay
I can go for an f7 strike oh it's kind
of fun
f7 okay we had this um I was talking
about this structure earlier in a five
minute game that I had the idea here is
to make sure that that LightSquared
Bishop does not get out of control I'm
looking to smash up on their structure
I haven't any of it Knight here I don't
want to take mmm okay I gotta defend
that pawn it's ready to take that night
out you're gonna have f6 now f6 is not
good I take an amount of queen and the
bishop
it's Knight is running out of squares
I'm gonna look for me I'm not gonna move
I was gonna go to f6 maybe it would have
been good Oh
what's happening with that move what's
happened what am i doing on my night
okay
I'm gonna do this now and then maintain
control over E and now c5 those brakes
aren't I'm on the bishop there's pins
and stuff
okay controlling e5 still and c5 pretty
sure I still have this
there wasn't a fork my knight was there
to defend no I could drop back and
defend my rook Knight checks knight
checks next oh they're gonna take my
rook I don't get their Queen I do
they should have block with their queen
I'm the bishop give a check here no
matter what there's no back rank issues
they're in check I get the bishop here
no matter what you're gonna get that
take the rook
here no matter what push my pawns
they're down on time back to chairman
seventy-two 5954 have any of these games
even ended if not play against Batman
just when you think the term maybe can't
get any tougher here you gotta you gotta
fight against Batman now Batman he will
put the fear right into you
rook b8 soften up this dark square rook
b8 put pressure on this pawn I still
want to do this I think it's still good
oh what's happening it's hard to avoid
g3 I just take and then Age 2 again
Queen takes Knight is probably the only
save can you believe that h2 that would
have been hard to defend anyhow back to
tournament ninety seventy seven fifty
six fifty five red mist have we played
before I wonder if I've played this guy
before or girl you never know you don't
know do you
alright let's get all my pieces working
Queen d2 I might throw my Jeep on
they're gonna they're gonna play a six B
five and or they're still prepping that
pawn advance might still be there if
this is definitely reckless but I'm
gonna try it definitely reckless but I'm
gonna try my knight is the one that
wants to recapture I have to be careful
of F 3 and C 4 okay this is where I was
going to go to anyhow f3 was on I'm
gonna take like this so I have play on
the G file
he's probably in terrible at now there's
dark square weaknesses so let's try and
take advantage of that fact
Bishop f3 and then kick this Knight and
then jump my in with jump my knight in
there with the tempo oh I have enough
defense the queen is not a good leader
when putting pressure along a file so 95
with tempo and now I'm going to first
take you know I want to do this first my
bishop is there to defend I want to be
able to hit the Queen and not have her
take here so there's Forks here but my
main objective is to get to f6 so I'm
gonna remove the knight next and then
jump into f6 and it's gonna be a big big
problem
I'm winning material no matter what I'm
pretty sure they resigned back to
tournament one 1097 8960 for less than
15 minutes remaining
less than 15 remain Nona fries again
we're gonna be having another tough
struggle maybe I could take this night
out now let's do this okay we're not
having that okay they're gonna take now
I'm gonna take now when are they gonna
take okay and well the LightSquared
bishop here's what I'm gonna do okay
what I was gonna do is drop my knight
back and then play f5 having a similar
structure we're gonna enter it's like
we're gonna plan this same thing again
the same type of formation okay I kicked
this Knight out of here and where are
the tricks
and avoid the night exchange that night
really gonna find a good home right here
I kick it away
let's lock this down let's get this
majority going and get this advanced in
over here play on the G file play on
that G file pod push I could have done
this night is unprotected I have to
watch out for pawn push with the tempo
on my rook but I could still capture the
knight pawn push I could take just take
take here I'm not a knight and then I
want to do this so I don't have to worry
about this pawn don't take with this so
this becomes an issue hmm what's
becoming an issue my King safety pawn
push is good no it's not good maybe okay
let's not even allow that pawn to move
that's not even allowed to move okay -
be careful Queen could put pressure in
this pawn I want to bring my clean up my
king up to defend the pawn for Queenie
to stuff less than 20 bring my King up a
little bit I don't need my Bishop around
anymore on that square let's give a
check let's Lock this down he's come
around in what direction I didn't mean
to do that I did not mean to do that
let's just do this open it up I'm gonna
take and now they're tied down and I
want to sneak in here let's take here
that's probably a bad move probably
could have pinned it I don't have any
time just want to take this pawn no
matter what back to tournament 130 117
131 17 109 less than 12 minutes
remaining
I was gonna go for some bad vinick's set
up now I have a sinner I'm gonna take
the pawn and look for maybe some stuff
against h7 my Knights pinned I'm not too
concerned about that they've helped
build my center so this is a little
sneaky I'm looking to push here kick the
night away and they were sniffing that
one out okay now the G follow an h-file
are ripped
open night is struggling to find a good
home pawn takes next free my bishop I
want to smash through in some way Knight
here and after a capture my queen gets
to h6 this Knight is a bit of a bug
though okay I should have done that
sooner you can't be he can't even be
taken I'm gonna sack this so my bishop
can see the world and now the King has
to be very careful very careful I want
to guard this square the Queen couldn't
go there though okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
switch roles here King is gonna be
towards the center they have to give up
material now and my king wants to go no
further let's get up wait to check not
so fast
okay convert this now here no matter
what
double up rooks on this pawn get these
pawns advancing with tempo this is not
the cleanest way to do this yeah
definitely not the cleanest way to do
this rook check should just taken that
why don't I take that start worked oh he
was overloaded at that point okay back
determent they resigned 150 137 129 112
less than ten minutes remain deagle
anise more Smith Maura declined accepted
all right keep my queen trained on this
diagonal Bishop f4 I could do this again
I'll be hesitant to do that if I don't
have my C pawn around should probably
take in okay f4 is weakened I want to
remove the dark square Bishop and then
plant knight on f4 one day one day I'll
take with the rook okay that my knight
is on his way to where Oh they repaired
f4 you can't code before now I don't
need a castle where does my knight
belong where did Oh g5 might be a pretty
good one watches over f7 puts pressure
on age 3 and E 4 I want to undermine
this structure if this pawn is hit on d6
I'll defend how with my rook I should
just take in the night he was a freebie
he was a freebie my rook has good file
movement he's good along this file and
the rank I like my knight better than
the bishop that's what I'm taking like
that I'm winning a rook now maybe that
was a mouse let Brooke in the corner
might have been what my opponent wanted
170 157 or 49 128 D for the benoni the
old benoni defense
efore f3 Bishop d2 a 6 we see a 6 hang
on to my tricky night-night c4 that was
my bad bishop that was just exchange for
my opponents good bishop although maybe
I should have even allowed that exchange
8 minutes remain they Castle down the
Queen side where I have a space
advantage because of this pawn right
here I'm looking to maybe even throw my
knight in but I really do want Knight a
4 to b6 I like this structure
considering taking here and still go
here take with my knight I want to open
up the C file it can't be contested C
file cannot be contested because I have
control over C 8 let me first do this
and then B 5 coming up you're gonna take
huh I don't know what I want to do
Oh pawn push is gonna be good with pawn
push on f3 I should not have allowed
that I should not have allowed that
so my queen is there to watch over efore
i want to get this in finally but not
just yet my rook would have been hanging
okay now this is finally opening up
bishop check maybe they should have
played their first now I have play on
the B file it takes I think I just pile
up instead of recapturing let's take
like this first I want to drop my Bishop
back and like get this battery on a
seven okay may threat the pond has to
push it's not being pushed a seven
that's me
190 189 177 whoa okay
six minutes six minutes remaining
let's try this something a little bit
different take out this Knight and then
work on putting pressure on the dark
squares he's a defender of the squares
in the center that are dark get rid of
him and then post up on this square so
if pawn push I take the knight now I'm
actually winning material because this
is a fork I have enough defense for it
so if push I would have taken and then
jump my knight in to d4 and tried to
secure his position take with the night
I'm on the bishop I want to just
complete development complete
development there's no need to take this
bishop but now there is my opponent
forced my hand and let's give a check on
castle or a queen exchange okay I'm
there to recapture and defend my seventh
rank if that happens and I don't want to
do what I don't want to give up that to
Rux for a queen so let's do this instead
now I could come here close to being in
May if they're not careful
Queen trade happening very soon 27
seconds 27 seconds
get my king position in there they have
to block otherwise I'm getting more
material King position King towards the
Senate
there's pond advancing and how do you
break through I like having pawns on
light squares I could do this now well
yeah it's still good King here then I
get it next he's passed I just want him
to advance actually no he's he's a weak
point
so let me target him let me target him
and stop this advance let's give a check
and convenience the King first that's
not the most convenient way to do it
let's do this it's a lot cleaner I just
have to watch out for that sneaky pawn
move sneaky pawn move no sneaky pawn
with King now comes over here let's get
this guy rolling they're down in time
back to turn me to 10209 197 oh free
keep on okay let's try see for a Bob
Phoenix setup maybe see what my opponent
does efore and then I get a grip over d5
could still be played but I'll grab some
space maybe first let's do this look can
you grab some space pawn push I think I
come here right away instead of taking
if I take right away I help out there
light square bishop so that's why I'll
maintain this tension I don't want to
help my opponent's pieces
let's grab some space I'm going to
develop my light my dark square Bishop
so that b6 could be met with b4 and not
the case actually the knight is there to
watch over that but I could put pressure
on him take him out and now maintain
this pawn on c5 have to be careful
sometimes there's some sacrifices on c5
and then an eventual pawn push where
there could be a fork on my bishop at
night but I don't see that happening I
have enough support for and now trying
to hit at the head of the pawn chain I
have enough support for that he's a dead
piece he's struggling to do something
good and let's get this guy working I
guess clean here hits this pawn 34
seconds bishop here bit pawn here I
think he turns out to be tip a dead
piece
I should just take in it or maybe not I
don't need to do that I'm I'm lacking a
plan right now I'm not sure what I'm
doing
let's take like this I don't want their
LightSquared Bishop to get working
let's take with the rook my knight needs
a better home although he is stopping
the Queen from doing stuff he's gonna go
soon lets me let me just watch over f4
and I'll take and I'll drop back if
attacked again although rook there what
it would have been interesting what
would have been my reply after that I'm
not quite sure okay King position next I
have control over all the dark squares
and I should probably get this pawn
rolling rook trade I'm able to get my
king to e5 you have a check King here is
gonna be good
they're gonna get material but no I play
here kick the King back I'm gonna hit my
night to avoid that let's avoid that
let's throw a check in time situation
maybe that's not a good move let's do
this instead they're gonna move they're
not moving huh what's going on oh they
gotta check the server oh yeah this is
these are precious seconds these are
precious seconds there's only a minute
47 46 45 back to tournament to 30 oh
just like that look at a minute 40 you
can't come back Ani minute 37 minute 37
oh man this game is not gonna end
anytime soon
in fact my Knights gonna get kicked
around oh that's not good
discovered at academic against my queen
against my queen it could happen any
time any time they've weakened their
Kings side gonna take and get me playing
the h-file grab this pawn next
I get at each stage two rook takes H 3 H
- H - might be there on the bishop
that's check unavoidable that's each - I
got it back - Terman 250 just call the
tournament just call it - 52 49
just call it please I have to go for a
quick f7 strike this game is not gonna
end can I get it can I get it can I get
it
oh I didn't get it I got a runaway
that's why this is not good it's not
good to do these things I would drop my
Bishop Knight here oh no no no no take
this guy I'm on the night I should take
the night maybe they resign I got this
Knight are they gonna resign I'm not
gonna resign good saying that I get
their Bishop made on g7 the rook all
they called it I think it's third I
think it's third I get third I didn't
get first what they call it those Cubans
came up right at the top there oh why
are we playing on they already called it
what do we get second place confetti
I'll take that oh man oh man - 57 two
fifty two forty nine 209 all right good
games oh very nice